vom urknall bis zur bundestagswahl
die kleine geschichte der großen
parteien bundestagswahl 2021 leute und
ihr dürft wählen
und jetzt der hammer
diese vier ist mein letzter als
bundeskanzlerin das erste mal seit 16
jahren wird die oder der nächste kanzler
in nicht angela merkel heißen angela
merkel bundeskanzlerin seit 2005 erst
wähler waren da zwei jahre alt sie ist
übrigens die erste die den kanzler job
freiwillig aufgibt und nicht am gewehr
typisch merkel so kein bock mehr batches
saucool aber nicht angela merkel kann
man ja nicht wählen was dann
wir stellen euch die großen sechs
parteien vor die es wahrscheinlich in
den bundestag schaffen
fangen wir an mit den beiden sogenannten
großen volksparteien die älteste zuerst
die spd die sozialdemokratische partei
deutschlands 404.000 mitglieder
durchschnittsalter 60 frauenanteil um
die 33 prozent stehen für arbeit
industrie sozialstaat gewerkschaften
gerechtigkeit tariflohn 35 stunden woche
keine atomkraft hat sie fest muss ja zu
europa der für alle frauenquote
tempolimit die spd ist alt sehr alt
älter als jede andere partei älter als
euro großmutter als der rc sogar älter
als zdf als sozialdemokratische partei
deutschlands gibt es sie seit 1890
ursprünglich waren das ultralinke
beinharte sozialisten revolution karl
marx proletariat gegen kapital das hört
man heute selbst bei den linken so nicht
mehr
und damals gab es noch viele arbeiter
und arbeiterinnen 60 stunden woche kein
urlaub und das schlimmste der job des
influenza es war noch nicht erfunden
sozialdemokratie war hip der erste
freigewählte präsident der weimarer
republik war friedrich ebert von der spd
das ist 100 jahre her und die einzigen
die 1933 im reichstag gegen adolf
hitlers ermächtigungsgesetz stimmten
waren 94 spd-abgeordnete also street
credibility haben die sozen nach dem
krieg begann der ewige volksparteien
veith cdu versus spd die union wollte am
liebsten alles privatisieren die spd
teile der industrie verstaatlichen die
grundsätze der sozialdemokratie haben
sich seit damals eigentlich kaum
geändert hier wahlspot von 1957 stadt
das schöne steuergeld sinnlos für
irgendwelche kanzler auszuwandern bäume
platz fahren immer lieber krankenhäuser
davon bauen und schulen sozial halt
schon 1966 ließ sich kein anderes
bündnis bilden als cdu und spd es gab
die erste große koalition ein bis heute
sehr beliebtes konzept bei der die cdu
regiert und keiner merkt dass die spd
auch mit macht die sozen waren immer die
partei der einfachen leute zum beispiel
fernsehen
willy brandt spd außenminister drückt
1967 den knopf der das fernsehen habe
ich mache aber ab man fragt sich
allerdings gab es damals eigentlich
keine frauen durften die nicht aus 1969
der erste spd bundeskanzler willy brandt
der kniefall in warschau haben ihn viele
übelgenommen die ostverträge
friedensnobelpreis 74 musste er leider
zurücktreten
uwe geschichte der typ da hinter ihm ein
enger mitarbeiter war leider ddr spion
ist uns allen schon passiert trotzdem
jetzt hatte die spd meinen lauf auf
brand folgte der nächste spd kanzler
helmut schmidt die leute aus vor
begeisterung ein erstwähler von damals
gerade war ich zum ersten mal wählen
habe ich mich sehr gut informiert und
wähle helmut schmidt
wow ein macher der schmidt die sturmflut
in hamburg der raf-terror
abrüstungsgespräche mit russland alles
immer mit kippe man schätzt allein seine
tabaksteuer hat in deutschland mehrere
schulen finanziert ja man durfte damals
im fernsehen auftauchen und wenn man
über helmut schmidt spricht auch nicht
okay 1982 wird kohl kanzler
das bedeutete für die spd 16 lange jahre
opposition die sozen trafen schon immer
seltsame entscheidungen bei der auswahl
ihrer kandidaten und verschlüssen seit
willy brandt 13 verschiedene
parteivorsitzender
wer alle namen korrekt aufzählen kann
bekommt und diese von mir heute selbst
ausgedruckte spd fahne geschenkt aber
1998 das jahr in dem dieser hit rauskam
wurde gerd schröder kanzler endlich
wieder regiert in einer koalition mit
den grünen
und so wie die merkel-cdu immer weiter
richtung spd driftete taumelte die
schröder spd immer weiter richtung cdu
der arbeitsmarkt wurde flexibilisiert
das arbeitslosengeld gekürzt
ein-euro-jobs mini-jobs
spitzensteuersatz gesehen hat vier die
agenda 2010 alles nicht mehr so wirklich
sozialdemokratisch
freiwillig wollte heute beschäftigt
schröder sich mit russischem gas und auf
ins tag mit hagebutten viele traten
enttäuscht aus der partei aus auch oskar
lafontaine der später vorsitzender der
linken wurde weil ihnen die spd nicht
mehr links genug war
seitdem gab es drei große koalition
zwölf der letzten 16 jahre waren groko
jahre mit juniorpartner spd
sie konnten sogar ein paar linke themen
durchboxen mindestlohn frauenquote in
börsennotierten unternehmen mietpreis
bremse eigentlich keine schlechte bilanz
trotzdem bei der letzten bundestagswahl
vor vier jahren holte martin schulz das
schlechteste spd ergebnis aller zeiten
und jetzt tritt also olaf scholz er hat
sich als finanzminister auch nicht
gerade als linker hervorgetan aber wenn
ihr sozialdemokratische ideen mögt 12
euro mindestlohn rechtsanspruch auf home
office vielleicht sogar mal wieder eine
vermögenssteuer alles forderungen der
spd kommen wir nun zur zweiten großen
volkspartei cdu csu
die union haben garantiert schon eure
großeltern gewählt nicht wundern die csu
gehört zur cdu die bilden eine 8 und
sehr geiles wort fraktionsgemeinschaft
die christlich demokratische union und
die christlich-soziale union zusammen
rund 536.000 mitglieder
durchschnittsalter 60 jahre frauenanteil
um die 24 prozent stehen für
konservative familienwerte europa kirche
sicherheiten arbeitsplätze bundeswehr
keine proben freigabe kein tempolimit
verkehr und wachstum konservativ halten
keine partei hat deutschland länger
regiert die union war in den
anfangsjahren der bundesrepublik der
chef der king der barbie nach dem krieg
wurden überall cdu verbände gegründet
und gleich die erste bundestagswahl 1949
haben sie gewonnen
ganz knapp vor der spd knapp vor der spd
die ja das klingt heute wie ein witz
gewinnt eine partei knapp vor der spd
bei hh
aber es war so aller erster
bundeskanzler wurde konrad adenauer
bamberg
kennt ihr nicht mehr der war auf der 2 d
mark münze die kennt ihr auch nicht mehr
wirtschaftswunderzeit es ging bergauf
kabeg autos viel zu essen und das
reichte auch schon als wahlkampfthema
auf dem ganzen leben blau sowie am bau
[Musik]
werden wahr was gutes man habe das
eigentlich abgeschafft
deutschland trat der nato bei und
orientierte sich richtung usa ist bis
heute so der feind lag für die union im
osten
achtung angst wahlkampf vor fast 70
jahren alle wege des marxismus zur nach
moskau der spd gemerkt es gab kein
instagram war alles ein bisschen sind
alter weißer mann vor allem weiß im
hintergrund keine experimente fertig
damit holt adenauer 1957 die absolute
mehrheit das muss man jetzt mal erklären
da hatte eine partei mehr stimmen als
alle anderen zusammen
das klingt ja heute völlig
die genau so 19 63 perm der nächste
cdu-kanzler ludwig erhard war später
auch mal auf la 2 d mark münze ich höre
auf der dritte christdemokraten kanzler
kurt georg kiesinger bis in die 60er
hatten die echten lauf
dann kamen die studenten unten
junge leute protestierten dagegen dass
viele cdu politiker zum beispiel kanzler
kiesinger auch schon mitglied in der
nsdap waren das hatte bis dahin keinen
so richtig gestört
komisch besonders wenn man immer
christliche werte so hoch hält also auch
diese protest führten dazu dass die cdu
1969 zum ersten mal in ihrer geschichte
in die opposition musste
viele mussten das wort opposition erst
mal googeln
es gab aber noch gar kein internet also
mussten sie in einem lexikon
nachschlagen das waren so dicke bücher
so was wie google nur ausgedruckt erst
13 jahre später konnte helmut kohl
wieder den chefsessel für die union
holen 25 jahre parteivorsitzender
ehrenamtlich was wir auch kommen vier
amtszeiten 16 jahre blieb kohl kanzler
auch weil 1990 ein kleines ereignis
namens wiedervereinigung der cdu noch
mal einen boost gab
aber es lief nicht mehr so gut
wirtschaftlich die arbeitslosigkeit
stieg kohl wurde nochmal zur birne die
wahlwerbung immer oder helmut kohl in
einer menschenmenge ohne frauen echt
jetzt
ich sehe keine einzige frau doch da
hinten 30
lassen wir gelten spiesser familie klar
geht immer
baby an der brust was in einem cdu spot
die wirtschaftsfreundlichkeit der cdu
führte zu legendären korruptions
geschichten amigo affäre illegale
parteispenden über das chaos nutzte
diese frau sie wurde die erste weibliche
parteivorsitzende einer großen
volkspartei 2000 war und den rest kennt
ihr 2005 wurde die bundeskanzlerin noch
2009 wurde sie noch mal kanzlerin gering
so wahr mir gott helfe ebenso 2013 das
haben wir gemeinsam geschafft und 2017
noch mal es liegt in unserer hand
die cdu unter merkel wurde
sozialdemokratischer und vor allem
grüner flüchtlinge atomausstieg
energiewende alles sachen die hätte
helmut kohl nicht mit der rohrzange
angefasst aber wie gesagt die wahl 20 21
läuft ohne merkel
armin laschet tritt an
der hat bisher das problem land
nordrhein westfalen regiert wünschte
auch keinem wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt
kann ich eigentlich cdu wählen ohne csu
zu wählen geht nicht diese extra
weißwurst gilt bis heute überall tritt
die cdu an außer in bayern da nur die
csu
am ende sitzen aber beide als eine
fraktion im parlament ist total unfair
aber alle versuche das zu ändern sind
gescheitert weil durch horror show immer
so gemacht
das waren die beiden größten
volksparteien vielleicht noch ein
abschließendes
da habe ich schon geschätzt aber diese
rosen sind willy brandt das ist aber
nett
ein weiterer fun fact 2005 also in dem
jahr als merkel kanzlerin wurde kam auch
schnappi das kleine krokodil in die
deutschen charts
das kam aus ägypten dass sie direkt am
nil zuerst war es in einem ei dann
schnappte es sich frei muss man wissen
er kriegt gerne auf weitere videos